joining us now the 2018 Pittsburgh
Steelers MVP in his third season in the
NF one of the most recognizable names
and faces already despite not doing this
for very long he is receiver juju Smith
Schuster juju great to talk to ya buddy
how's it going I'm doing great how you
doing well it's doing great we
appreciate tide very much for making you
available we'll talk more about what
you're doing with tide coming up but but
obviously this is a good time for us to
talk to you I don't know how much you
want to be talking to media given what's
going on with the team but from your
perspective Mason Rudolph in Ben
Roethlisberger out what's your biggest
challenge is you get back to work
tomorrow to get ready to play games with
a different quarterback um you know just
good in that chemistry obviously I
played it with Mason before and we had
that there's times or you know bending
it practices he had it rest up and me
masonry uid and we you know we have that
connection but that chemistry you know
it's his first game I first start
obviously and it'll be away it gets the
49ers so he's super excited to see what
he can do and what we can show the world
how much of a leadership void is created
by Ben Roethlisberger being done for the
year and who replaces him in that
capacity I mean he will always be our
leader years old he always has that role
obviously he'll still be around us are
on a team still being able to you know
talk to us and you know coaches up our
other captain obviously is Marcus bouncy
a guy you know on offense you know he
shows by his actions and he's very vocal
too cam Hayward is our keeper said
leaders so we have so many guys on the
team who's well cool and was able to
fill those roles it's gotta be strange
for you dude yeah look around and say
man the world has changed a lot in a
very short period of time what does that
do to you from the standpoint of maybe
forcing you to to step up and be more of
a leader do you feel that obligation
falling on your shoulders even though
you're still fairly young in comparison
to your teammates almost definitely
obviously you know being the guy in our
room just based off of you know the
amount of plays the amount of experience
that I have with this team is
unbelievable and you know it's it's it's
crazy because I'm a guy who's 22 talking
to guys who are 28 25 who's all older
than me and for myself you know it'd
just be myself
being more vocal for the guys in my room
and you know as a team you know I just
got to step up and make those plays and
show by you know my actions and even say
a few things when you were named team
MVP last year did you feel that that
kind of elevates you and gives you the
credibility to say more and do more from
a leadership standpoint I'm not
necessary necessarily obviously for
myself you know I'll thought of as you
know was unbelievable honor you know to
receive this but you know very humbling
for my teammates and you know for those
guys you know everything that we've been
through
but like you says and now you know the
situation that's going on you know being
more vocal be more of a leader and you
know speaking out more how much will the
offense change with Mason Rudolph under
Center I don't think it would change a
lot you know obviously we have our place
we have you know the guys that used to
have an offense side of the ball and
every position that we need and I don't
think a lot would change you know when
seven was out there he's a guy who could
come up with plays on a field and no
huddle was a huge factor what he had in
his game and you know like I said of
this game I hear just upcoming game will
show a lot and I don't think a lot will
change to out you know throughout the
season
give us a sense juju from a football
standpoint the difference between these
two guys how the ball comes out how they
throw it how they drop back how they
survey the field as you're running pass
routes what's going to be different when
you look back into the into the pocket
and see Mason Rudolph there instead of
Ben Roethlisberger um I mean you talk
about a guy who's been in lead for 15
years and you talk about a guy who's
been lead for two years a huge
difference obviously Ben has experience
and he's played in big games he played
in situations where you know stirred out
and long and stuff like that and Ben has
a special touch his gold bars are very
you know very beautiful you know rained
out for those and you know with Mason
obviously you have a guy who's able to
do all those things but the difference
is it's like the time experience that
they played in their careers how do you
think Mason did on the fly being thrust
into this on Sunday from the outside it
looked like he did fairly well what was
your assessment of his performance I
think he did very well you know he you
know his number was called he was on the
field he made those plays and he put
points on the board that's all that's
all it's about you know he
we put points on the board and that's
what's huge you know that's what we got
to do on our office I'd about we've got
to convert more on der downs and move
the chains just so we can score more in
you know keep the momentum on office
special team defense give me one thing
that Mason Rudolph does that you look at
and say you know what he's got that down
pat he may have to work on other things
but this is one thing that he can do at
the NFL level oh man those deep balls
he's really good at those Agra season he
has posited those deep balls over Donner
field and you know I've seen him doing
in college with James Washington so I'm
not surprised you know that's something
he's really good at he said something
yesterday that he was aware for a while
that Ben was having some sort of an
elbow issue when did it first hit your
radar screen that we may need to keep an
eye on what happens with this elbow on
Ben and we may need to make an
adjustment
out of the blue during a game to a new
quarterback yeah so I I was probably
like dirty game actually I've noticed
that you know who was grabbing his form
and that's when I was like okay what I
mean there's something serious going on
with that situation going on
I did say okay he's gonna come back
right cuz you know it's Big Ben he'd
love to get him he's in the five baggie
that's what I usually do and when they
pulled him they put Maci now so I was
something serious and when I thought
about the news it wasn't well I didn't
take it you know very lightly I was it
was a tough one you know for myself
because I played him for the past two
years and you know not to see a guy who
loves again so much goes down but you
know just a great leader a great player
all the way around and you know for us
you know in our room coach Thomas
talking about you guys stay positive you
gotta believe and then we too and that's
what we know we all do we all believe in
to the haze and go out there get the job
done from your perspective this is all
happening in a unique season where
you're shifting from the number two
receiver on the team to the number one
receiver on the team what differences
have you noticed through two games and
how defenses cover you given that you're
now the guy on the receiving depth chart
yeah I mean there's a lot of double-team
a lot of you know me be matched up with
their best corner you know it's just
it's awesome you know how the
opportunity gets them go against from
great guys and some great defense but
you know being able to be a to take
those double teams and have other guys
make their plays and all the way around
so it's heel
has changed you know the inside-outside
and in a Williamson everyone guy
do you hear more chatter now from
defensive back since they're focused on
you instead of a be none not so much I'm
very I'm pretty fun out there I just a
good job or a smile or some guys don't
even talk like Gilmore didn't talk to me
a lot um but towards end the game you
know he smiled at me and I was like okay
there you go like nice mom's they
obviously they won but I'm not the type
of guy to talk you know that that kind
of stuff but to ask um today I'm still
not talking hey you're with us today on
behalf of Todd tell us what you have
going on with them obviously there's a
big debate obviously Todd has teamed up
with the NFL and NBC there's a debate
about you know Wendy do your laundry on
Sundays and for myself I do laundry so
on Tuesdays why because and if though
Sunday's are for the NFL not for laundry
and for myself
I do laundry on Tuesday because it's an
off day it's the best way to go I use
tripods why you're so easy just throw it
in there like a football and there you
go not used to going touchdown so you
can do your laundry it's over it's clean
now you got fresh underwear so now wait
a minute you're 22 years old right yeah
and you stand you actually and you're 22
and you do your laundry I got a son who
just turned 23 this weekend he went he
would not do laundry if his life
depended on it you do laundry at 22 huh
yeah that's good I'll tell him I'll tell
him I'll get him some Tide Pods and he
could go into my shame so easy
he doesn't have to you know be 22 21
you know in college career like you age
you're not really focused on that you
just throw it in there the tripods so
easy way to get I think he's a the only
thing easier than the tide pot juju is
giving the bag to mom and saying hey mom
watch my clothes here are the Tide Pods
you do it for me they hate one last
question for you make a fitzpatrick now
a member of this deal is what was your
reaction when you heard the news on me I
mean talk about a great player you know
all the way around please inside outside
you know
had the chest plate against him in
college and you know going to get some
he's very pissed who got my guy who
makes plays he's been making plays past
two years and we had a huge pickup for
us you know I'm super excited to see
where they play my how to use him but
he's coming here making plays too so
there's not a lot about you know the
picking what they trade it for and his
trade comes at a time when people are
like oh boy no Ben Roethlisberger for
the season it's kinda know what kinda
send to you guys that the team's given
up next year's first round pick to get
help right now on the defensive side of
the ball I mean is just for us you know
I mentioned to the world is that like
we're not giving up or not this is a
huge year for us and even though our our
best player is out that doesn't mean
that you know we don't fight to go when
you know more games and we're not
conference play when a SC and then win a
Super Bowl so all this you were looking
now or not think about the future
alright buddy well hey it's Tuesday so
go do your wash you already know baby
all right man good talk to you pal good
luck with everything
sir you too
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports